hey rejects its Greg here win really big
really big V I'm never telling yes to
say that yeah but we just saw each other
for miss slum we're now trying to keep
the political nests going with the
official trailer for Barry I could be
wrong but I think this is about a young
Barack Obama if you guys know Barack
Obama is it Kimberly he's our he's our
president currently seem to not be in
the office anymore you might have missed
that you might have missed I know you
don't want a TV you don't own internet I
you don't know what we're doing here
you've never seen a camera but well
Bacon's up there so I don't I understand
okay this is about a guy that used to be
our president yeah I mean he still is
our president kinda what is he now he's
still our president so January when the
greatest man in the world is gonna take
over
I can't wait for Trump's Merrick okay
not gonna get in any more I'm done
enough videos about it let's watch Barry
and you carry it as far as you can oh
yeah rubbing into thank you for a while
to really
is that by saying what is your scene I'm
still trying to figure that out
nice you know I'm the only black person
it for my five classes but you're that
white too
you can fit in anywhere I'm a student
here ID I don't I don't see you I beam
then so what's so special about me
they're gonna be President
I believe in the people creating jobs
mouse mechana sand my dad's from Kenya
and you know what that makes you
so I don't it makes you American
well said
they were going to answer that for a
second I know why Barry Barak very very
good cast
Netflix delivers man they're on fire it
really are I really have a lot of stuff
going on right now
you know an Oliver Stone did like that W
movie about George Bush I didn't really
care for the fact that it was covering
so much like I thought it was trying to
cover way too much like his whole life
leading up to his presidency and then at
during his presidency and this feels
just like yes feels contain like the
college sort of yeah who he became yeah
exactly who he became in order to become
the man who would one day run for
president yeah this is about his whole
upbringing in his young life and we saw
that he liked white girls he liked white
chicks that was Barry I mean that was
blackberry I don't know but he
eventually found a black woman tell
Obama yeah it was like one of the
raddest 20% black
Michelle I believe no if I facts are
correct she's 20 percent African but we
see here that he was boning a white
chick early on Barack you're the man wow
you're the man I hear once you go black
you don't go back is that true Kimberly
would you know that while you're married
to a white guy I take the fifth okay
okay fair enough
okay I don't go back I don't set them
you don't but you don't go back from
anybody on a technical scale I think
this this looks shot really well I like
I like seeing the era brought to life I
like seeing the lifestyle this a man
who's playing Barack Obama I haven't
ever seen him in anything before I have
not either who one who is that well
that's where we have IMDB created for
I wouldn't have top billing I'm here
because he's black okay I know I'm gonna
go with because there are other bigger
names in the film because it seems that
the cast was pretty was pretty strong
Devin Devin Tyrell Tyrell all right wow
this is like this first credited project
I love that congratulations man good job
man we're clearly gonna be seeing more
of you yeah I mean a movie with all the
reviews on that trailer stand to be
truth
it looks pretty solid and I like the
film quality of it it doesn't feel like
it's overdone and not so like just been
clean and like blue skies II and it
feels like a real like movie like in in
terms of it doesn't feel like a
made-for-tv kind of film though it's on
Netflix it feels like a real actual life
no no they don't I think that's one of
the great things about them is that
they're they're made-for-tv movies feel
a lot more than just that but I'm
wondering how accurate all this stuff is
gonna be I didn't know he grew up in
Indonesia for a lot well there's the
whole question of like his birth who
said that
Trump but then he took it back I don't
think Trump is the kind of guy to ask
our president some kind of no I'm a
really insulting question like anybody
about I just mean how dare you why would
you make an accusation that's just not
true imagine him being mean not my job
no no so I didn't know that either but
there was that whole controversy if you
will I mean I don't think that they put
it in a movie in lie about it I mean
ours is everything that you see is real
yeah never alive especially in Hollywood
I don't want to come across like the
worst person alive right now
because I'm probably going to come
across like a horrible human being the
only the only stuff I don't really care
for her when I see like a trailer like
this it's probably just the trailer and
when i watch the actual movie and it's
complete format I attend Sanaa bother me
I still find it very effective when I
see the trailer when it's like oh the
cop is being mean to the black guy and
that's you know racist stuff where he's
in a hallway then he gets punched in the
face I can't help but feel like it's
like a cliche moment to show in a
trailer
usually in a movie okay full context it
works for me it's a
active in a trailer I feel like it's a
little too much like a little kind of in
my face about it I can understand that
that's a fair point now that I said it
it does kind of feel like taking it back
because I think what your let me tell
you what you're saying okay or what
maybe I heard um that we expect that to
be a part of his journey but it's
something that sort of regularly happens
in our world it's not unexpected so to
put it in there we would probably
imagine that that was going to be a part
an aspect of the film anyway yeah maybe
that's maybe what I'm saying I just feel
slightly loses its impact okay when it
just seems like it's kind of done in a
cliche format but I'm sure in the film's
context that will probably be very
effective
we have shawol portrayal of it we hope
that and I hope we get a sex scene with
Barak and the white chick interracial
lovemaking if what movies complete
without yeah I bet Barack had some 8
millimeter footage of him doing that
with whoever that lady is talent that is
talented that was great the talent 8
millimeter oh that's a detail to the
joke right I like the hair I like them
up there the hair the hair is there I'm
really on board for this honestly I feel
like this this whole this whole
experience is probably gonna be very
worthwhile
obviously when Barak stops being
president there's gonna be a movie about
a man like to see yes who did this one
though like is this going to be the
movie about Barack Obama or is there
going to subsequently be the Oliver
Stone version Oh Vikram Gandhi oh yeah
he's he's good know from vice wait you
haven't watched that on HBO you should
it's an amazing unbiased new this people
might get mad that I said unbiased but I
don't think it's biased it's just to the
point so you know any political video
you put on YouTube people are gonna
backlash yeah anything you say okay
yeah anything you say black lives matter
I'm putting that out there right now I
don't want anyone to think that like
just because I said the whole thing
about this simi cliche means I'm against
that her son
anyway yeah although real quick I'm
sorry can I can I park on this real fast
it is pretty cool though like because
I'm sure that was a part of his life
yeah those moments that I found to be
cliche in a trailer it is pretty cool to
be like it's pretty it's pretty awesome
the man wasn't able to still rise and
become president in the United States he
now that I mean and I feel like that's
what was cool about the trailer the
trailer wasn't making me go
leading up to him being president I was
getting so pulled into whoever this
person was and what they were going
through at this time instead of being
aware like he's going to be President
one day like I feel like a lot of these
stories would do that's true and I like
because there was a line in there where
they brought up change which was his
whole campaign platform and beginning
anyway and he said that what was it that
he believes people people are the cause
of change or people can earn you know
the people can make the change I'm just
saying that even then he had a different
perspective on the world coming from his
background in his situation that would
lead him up to becoming the most
powerful man in the free world one of my
favorite I've ever heard of the WTF what
the [ __ ] with Marc Maron no it's this
podcast show and he had Barack Obama on
there for an hour
it's an hour-long podcast and I listened
to the whole thing and one of my
favorite things about Obama was
listening to his point of views his
philosophies towards life is attitude
towards people that's what's intriguing
to me about this trailer is seeing how
all that not really his political views
but its views towards people in life in
general that's what seems to be forming
here from watching this story I like
that they're going for a real personal
approach yes instead of trying to make a
political movie yeah the man behind the
man the man behind the man yeah was a
black man yes once you go black you
don't go back apparently no not saying
Barack was gay
it doesn't matter if he was gay they
said man behind the man I said it was a
black oh I I thought your main engage oh
no I playing longer gauge oh no it was
it was you said yeah you know you didn't
class you are nothing
hey all this teachers at war laughing or
watching okay 90% gage you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today
Kimberly Biggs V as on it's Kimberly
Biggs me on Instagram full of beautiful
photos and tweets I at Kimberly Biggs me
where it is
beautiful tweets I'm an inspiring
tweeter are you really I am I don't
think I've read a single tweet of yours
well because I I have not been super
active it as of late but if you like go
back in my feet okay
oh all you do is write to eat what not
every day and only when I think things
are relevant
she said August 16th on forget about the
before and the after focus on the right
now
what's that lips yeah I'm a big emoji
lover oh wow yeah I believe a prostitute
said that to a character in Game of
Thrones when he couldn't get into it
then he was like just don't she was
trying to say like don't worry that it's
prostitution forget about the before it
was focused on them right now and then
she kissed him this is a game of Thrones
Club